you think of my makeup that good did you
do a good job what part did you do yeah
what else did you do my lipstick why it
did my lipstick hey guys I'm Hannah the
world's okay his mom and welcome to my
bathroom if you're a busy parent like me
you know that mornings with kids are the
most hectic time of day I'm not paying
attention to what I'm wearing or how I
even look as long as my kids have pants
good to go one thing I've heard is that
if you want to try something but you
don't have the time for it
outsource it so per your suggestions I'm
gonna have my two kids do my makeup for
a week my six-year-old and my
three-year-old boys are going to do my
makeup for a week I think this is gonna
be a disaster
but this is what you guys wanted and
best-case scenario you know they enjoy
themselves and I learn a couple makeup
tips so wish me luck a question do you
undo my makeup today yeah okay my kids
relationship with makeup thus far is
kind of just this like mysterious thing
that mom has in her purse that you're
not allowed to touch so you really want
to touch it and like make a huge mess of
it like gum I can't even tell you how
many times Wyatt has taken my colour-pop
liquid matte lipstick and put it on
himself and then lost the tube there
probably under a random piece of
furniture just like slowly staining
everything because if anybody owns that
you know how much it gets all over
everything and it does not come off I
didn't really give my kids any
guidelines I just gonna spread it out
like a big smorgasbord I realized very
quickly that that was not the way I
should have approached things because
all they did was take their makeup
brushes and mix every single makeup that
was out there together and just pile it
all over my face it's like when you're a
little kid in a restaurant you have a
fountain drink up and you decide to like
get a little bit of every flavor cuz it
seems like a cool idea but it actually
tastes really bad that's basically how
the first day went okay so this is me
ready for the day that's concealer and
they did my eyebrows and mascara and
eyeshadow and blush didn't really blend
my concealer and my lips you guys happy
with your work yeah it's really funny
because I didn't give anyone a heads up
on this experiment but the second I
walked into work everyone was like do
you like my makeup looks like someone
special put it on you knew children
everybody knows yeah we are trying a
makeup look today that is called high
school dance that's what the boys picked
um I'm hoping that when they're done I'm
going to look ready for homecoming I
have my coffee oh you're cool and a
whole spread of makeup out and ready for
them to use so are you guys ready to do
it we decided that I was gonna pull up a
list of different makeup looks and
they'd get to choose one I'd pull up an
image of what it looks like and then
show them the brush and like the shade
that they would use to achieve that and
then they took that and ran with it
and it went a lot smoother as far as
like not ruining all the makeup that I
just bought but they're not they're just
not good at doing makeup and this was a
look with a lot of like heavy eyeshadow
highlighter lots of blush like pretty
lips but they were doing it at like 8:30
in the morning so it looked very
ridiculous this is my homecoming luck
spent a lot worse than I thought it
would I don't want to leave I really did
not think it could look Oh get your
pants on okay go get your pants on today
we're gonna do a natural look because I
feel like less makeup is better do you
know how to do a natural look plus I
chose a natural makeup look because
there's only so much you can mess up
with nude eyeshadow and it really does
Wow so I just needed a little break from
from the intensity and also my skin
needed a break I was getting like very
irritated eyes and I figured this would
give them a chance to adjust thank you
you did a good job here's my completed
natural look the lips are a little bare
like the corners were not completely
done I don't know if Y was going for
like a 20s flapper look but the
eyeshadow colors are pretty good I
really think the natural look is the
best look so far because there was less
for them to mess up I did ask Matt how
he thought the makeup looked you look
beautiful
just gorgeous and he could not tell the
difference between the way I do my
makeup and the way the kids did my
makeup which I think says something
about my makeup abilities so I think
we're gonna do a smokey eye yeah and
lipstick
are you guys getting better at this yes
yeah I don't know about that I don't
know what it is with kids instincts they
just want like the darkest most like oh
like noticeable thing like they were
just like itching to use the dark colors
and they were dying to use my eyeliner
there were some things that I just
didn't have them use one of which was my
eyeliner pen because I didn't want to
lose an eye I didn't want that in a two
year olds hands anywhere near my face oh
so I caved this time and I let them use
the eyeliner so Jackson was in charge of
doing the eyeliner and I totally
understand what happened with him
Jackson started doing the eyeliner and
was
one of those things like I can relate
like when you're doing your winged
eyeliner and you get a part wrong and
you end up like just making it thicker
and thicker and thicker until it's
covering your entire eye that's kind of
what happened here it happens two grown
women like I can't fault him for it it
was a solid effort I look like I slept
in my makeup oh my god I do not want to
go out like this I just wear my
sunglasses all day might be a little bit
of a cop-out if you agreed for them to
do your makeup oh this day got a lot
more reactions than the first day I had
gone to work with the makeup why are you
wearing oh I I walked out to meet Nick
to go to lunch and his immediate
reaction was like where are you going
you're not going to lunch looking like
that yes we are why would you
rock'n'roll high school they kept asking
to do rock and roll high school makeup
because they're obsessed with the
Ramones what is that oh it's a song
wanna do a makeup look based on rock and
roll high school okay we'll see how that
turns out it's like you know when kids
just like throw out arbitrary phrases
for stop where they're like I just want
I want spider-man waffles and I'm like
we don't have something what constitutes
a spider-man waffle I don't know if
these are meant to be second eyebrows or
eyeliner but they're there you can't
really see how much eye shadow is like
dusted under here and I'm afraid to
touch it because I feel like it's all
gonna smear but this was the first day
that they started actually asking me
like where does this go where do I put
this how do I blend it and they were
super into like learning the intricacies
of doing makeup why it will even like
take a little makeup like a little eye
shadow on the brush and hold it up and
be like like and then put it on me it
was like so funny to see them do it if
I'm looking like this
everywhere you can't really tell but
also my face just overall looks a lot
Pinker than the rest of my body but if I
go like this if I walk around like this
all day no one will notice
today is glitter day Wow okay alright
let's do it
they had also been eyeing the sparkle
eye shadows for a very long time and the
highlighter that I bought they did like
a My Little Pony glitter princess
highlighter all over my entire face
makeup look look at that brush this
brush is a glitter forest I don't know
if you can tell there's glitter
everywhere and why it kind of painted
the sides of my face and today is the
day that I have to go grocery shopping
nice
I love grocery shopping it's like my my
happy place my special time and I really
didn't want to go in this makeup that is
some shiny all over my face even above
my mouth alright here goes nothing we're
going in I didn't want to risk not being
able to go back to not trigger Jose out
of embarrassment and I didn't want to
risk being known as like the woman with
the weird makeup
every time I blink there's like a
glitter puff that flies off the cashier
was super nice to me I know that they
were probably like holding in there
laughter the entire time but they were
very kind and I got through the entire
shopping experience unsaved for the most
part so today we're doing fancy makeup I
don't quite know what that means about
why it's gonna take the lead apparently
what it means is blue and green
eyeshadow to match my hair which is it's
cute in theory but they were trying to
do some under eye like shadow had ended
up just kind of circling the bottom and
making me look like I had been punched
in both eyes and then Jackson who had
been practicing lipstick this whole week
was like I want to do your lipstick and
he whips out my lip sends the second he
pulled out the wand
I had flashes of like the Joker makeup
stuck on my face he actually did a
really good job and I'm super super
grateful
I guess fancy makeup means blues and
greens and very very bright red lipstick
I'm gonna add a little mascara to this I
just I can't have them do it because
there is the nice you can help me
overall like from here down I looked
okay and then from here up I looked like
I had gotten in a severe fistfight so my
god to work that day and really of all
the days this day had the most at stake
because there was a meeting with my team
and some clients calling it on video
chat so I told myself on video they're
not gonna be able to see very well like
it's gonna be blurry but then my
coworker walked in and all of that
immediately went down the drain we are
caught into this meeting it looks like
we got punched
I well they're not gonna speak of home
video no you need to take that off I
have a solution for this so I probably
looked super hungover but after seven
days of this experiment
I'd much rather look hungover than like
a crazy makeup lady so what did I learn
from this seven days of complete madness
well first I learned that I could afford
to spend a little more time on my makeup
in the morning there's a lot of stuff
that I could try and it really doesn't
take that long to do something fun and
unique with makeup and actually put a
little bit of effort into it and it's
it's fun I want to do more of it and I
want to try more second I learned that
my kids bless their hearts they think
I'm beautiful no matter what through
this whole experiment every day no
matter how horrendous my makeup looked
they would be constantly encouraging me
constantly telling me how beautiful I am
and how awesome I am and how great I
look it was so nice to just see that
what's on the surface is not what they
see they just genuinely love me a lot
and I love them a lot they're happy with
me no matter how I look and third I
realized that my kids likely will never
be makeup artists not in the near future
not ever probably not even artists but
you know that's okay go be an athlete go
be a scientist go be an engineer pay for
my nice nursing home love you Thanks
remember your mom just dumped do my
makeup or anyone elses all right guys I
did it go easy on me because I'm still a
beginner but I did it anyway that's all
I got for today I'm Hannah and
I learned a lot in this experiment but I
got a note have you guys ever let your
kids do your makeup or are you gonna let
your kids to your makeup because if so
leave it in the comments I really want
to know that I'm not alone and if you
really want to make my day text me a
picture of how it looks this is a real
number and I read every single one and
I'd love to see what your kids come up
with because hopefully it's better than
what my kids did now if you'll excuse me
I have to get out of the house because I
have makeup on today and like I need
somebody to see it even if it's just my
grocery store cashier til next time
[Music]
thank god there's a mouth hole office